Ah, the joys of the
modern digital age.
Now as far as ages
go, we've clearly
entered into the Cambrian
explosion of digital content.
You see, we have
plethoras of data
out there on the internet--
books, music, videos,
even your favorite TV shows
are all available at the touch
of a button or a
finger to any device
you want, anywhere in the world.
Now think about
this for a minute.
I mean, we're talking about
yottabytes upon exabytes
upon googles of information.
All flowing through
the internet,
everywhere in the world,
every second of the day.
Now since the late '70s,
information theorists
and computer scientists have
been utilizing compression
algorithms to effectively
reduce the size of this content,
to keep the internet from
coming to a standstill.
And this is why today we
start hearing more and more
about the connection between
conversion rates and data sizes
for applications and websites.
So for example, a user may
browse away from a website
if it hasn't loaded
in three seconds
or may not download an
application because it
can incur extra charges
by their carrier.
Now savvy developers need to
take control of this fact.
And that means bucking
the trend of just using
standard compression
algorithms out there.
Instead, you need to
start digging in deep,
understanding your data,
and utilizing compression
in new and interesting ways
to make your users happy.
But fear not, young developer.
I'm here to help
with that process.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and this is Compressor Head.
In 1836, an American inventor
named Samuel F. Morse
concocted a way to
send electrical pulses
through a wire.
Now, at the end of
that wire was actually
attached an electromagnet.
Himself along with
other physicists,
realized that if they
could separate out
the pulses of
electricity on the wire
to control the
electric magnet, they
could ring a bell every
time a pulse came through.
And thus was born the
electrical telegraph system.
You see, the entire
intent of this operation
was to find a way to
send natural language
code over great distances,
using a pretty robust medium.
Now of course, they
needed to figure a way
to devise a situation
where they could
take an English
character-- a, b, or c--
and actually turn it
into electrical pulses--
dot dash dot dot dash.
And thus was born Morse Code.
The way they were able
to assign this code
was actually based on
the inverse frequency
of a symbol occurring
in the English language.
So for example, e, the most
common occurring letter
in the dictionary, actually
was assigned the smallest code.
The reason for this was
you have to remember,
they have some guy
sitting there banging
on the electrical magnet,
sending pulses through a wire.
And they wanted to minimize
the amount of work that
needed to be done to
communicate a message.
And of course, all of
the other symbols on here
are based upon
their probability.
Getting more complex, the less
probable they are to occur.
Now in modern
computing, we actually
use a different sort of form.
And that's actually
called binary code.
Now binary code is not a
variable length symbol.
Instead what we
say is that you're
going to use a set
number of bits,
and then we're able to
assign a symbol to a given
number of bits using
that static amount.
So for example, ASCII
assigns eight bits
to a single character.
So when we get a stream
of these bits on the wire,
we know we can read in
eight bits at a time
and determine what symbol
we're actually using.
Now however, if we decided
to move the other direction
and implement a frequency
change, much like Morse
did-- sorry.
You see that we can actually
get to something a little bit
better.
Now what happens here is
if we take into account
the probability or frequency
occurrence of the character
and use that to assign
a variable length bit
pattern to it, we
can actually start
getting some interesting things.
So for example, c occurring
in a given symbol stream
80% of the time, gets assigned
the shortest character,
a single zero.
Now what this means is
instead of assigning
eight bits per character
for our entire stream,
we can actually assign a
variable length of characters
and actually end up in this
example getting 81% savings.
This is the definition
of variable length codes.
And it's what we're going
to talk about more of today.
Now it would seem that you
can't really have a discussion
about compression without
actually going back and talking
about information theory itself.
And when you're talking
about information theory,
you can't talk about
it without introducing
this guy, Cloud Shannon.
Now Cloud, who besides being
awesome at parties-- really
good with keg
stands-- pretty much
invented what we call
modern information theory.
Now what Cloud did
effectively was
he found that there was a
correlation between information
content and the probability
of that symbol occurring
in the stream.
Now he was able to
actually measure
this correlation with
the logarithm function
and actually get a result
in the number bits.
So effectively,
he could find out
what the information content
was in terms of binary data.
Now this itself was
a pretty bold move
that actually defined how
information theory works.
But for our needs, what
we're more interested
with is his
definition of entropy.
See, when you take all of
the probability content
and information content of a
stream and sum it together,
you end up with the
algorithm for entropy.
Now besides being
a little gnarly
here, what we really find out
is that entropy is actually
a matching of an estimate for
the minimum number of bits
that each symbol has
to have on average
to represent the stream.
Don't worry, we'll take
a look at an example
of that real quick.
So let's take a look
at this in practice.
So let's say we
have a stream that
only has two symbols in
it, whose probabilities are
represented by P1 and P2.
So you can see here that while
the probability is 0.5 and 0.5
between these two symbols,
the entropy value actually
gives us 1.
Basically saying that
we need 1 bit per symbol
to represent all symbols
in this stream, right?
So two symbols, we have 0 or 1.
That's pretty good.
Now as we start skewing
the probability,
effectively one
symbol starts becoming
more dominant in the stream
than the other symbol.
So we start seeing
the probability
of P1 start rising
and P2 start falling.
We can see that the entropy
value ends up at about 0.88.
Roughly meaning that on average,
we need 0.88 bits per symbol
to represent all the
symbols in the stream.
And this is good, right?
This is where we come back
to variable length codes.
Some codes are bigger,
some codes are shorter.
To further this
point, you can see
that we're really skewed
down here in 0.99 and 0.01.
The entropy is as
close to 0 as it
can get, meaning
that we're going
to see a lot of bias for
P0 and a large code for P1.
Let's look at this a bit more.
So let's say we have something
very simplistic here.
We've got four symbols, right?
And each one has an equal
probability of 0.25.
Now in this environment,
the entropy is actually 2.
So we have to have
minimum 2 bits per symbol
to represent all the
symbols in this stream.
Which actually boils down
to something that looks like
this-- 00, 01, 10, and 11.
This is pretty much the
basis of how binary works.
If you know the number
of bits per symbol,
you can read it pretty easily.
Now to look at entropy
a little deeper.
If we actually start changing
the probability of the symbols
in the stream, we get
some different results.
So let's say we
have a set-up here,
where we've got four
symbols, and each one
has a different probability,
0.49, 0.25, 0.25, and 0.01.
When you actually run this
through the entropy equation,
you end up with about
0.157 bits per symbol.
Again, this is on
average, right.
Now this means that we can
start assigning variable length
codes to the stream to
start achieving compression.
Because we really can
only get compression once
we have differing probabilities.
So in this case, A, being
the most dominant symbol,
actually gets the smallest
code word of 1 bit per symbol.
And over time, we're going
to end up with compression.
Now remember that
entropy actually
represents the best estimate
of the minimum number of bits
required to
represent the stream.
And of course, that also
brings us into the next point.
If you're going to be
using variable length codes
and get compression
out of them, you
need to make sure that
you assign the shortest
codes to the most frequent
symbols in your stream.
If you don't follow
this principle,
you're not going
to get compression,
and you're really not
going to have a good time.
So now let's take a
look at how you actually
use these variable length
codes in your software
to start encoding and
decoding your data stream.
So let's say we start with
our symbol stream A, B, C.
And of course, we also
have a symbol table.
Now a symbol table is going to
map your given symbols-- A, B,
and C-- to your given variable
length code words, VLCs.
So A goes to 0, B goes to 10,
and C of course goes to 11.
Now encoding is actually
extremely straightforward.
All we have to do is read
a symbol off the stream,
figure out what code word
it goes to, and then output
that code word to
the bit stream.
So let's see what
that looks like.
We take an A off the stream.
And of course we find that
A just goes to a single 0.
So we can simply output a
single 0 to the bit stream.
Now of course we take B
off the symbol stream.
Look through our
symbol table and find
that B corresponds to 1 and 0,
which is pretty easy for us.
We again put up a 1 and
then put up a 0 as well.
And of course C, the final
one here, goes to 1 1,
which again is
pretty easy to do.
Now the encoding process here
is actually not that difficult,
as I said.
We start with symbols, we moved
to code words, and it's done.
Now decoding is a little
bit trickier though.
Because in decoding,
we effectively
have to start with
our bit stream,
and then read
through and determine
what symbols we're
working towards.
Now here's the tricky part.
Because our code words are
actually variable length,
we don't know how
many bits to read.
Let's take a look
at what that says.
So we start with our
input stream, 01, 01, 1.
Now we read a single
bit off of the stream.
We check this against
our symbol table.
And we realize that the first
symbol is actually an A, right?
A is a single 0, we got a
single 0 off the stream,
so we can actually put
A in the output stream.
Now we read the next
bit off the stream.
And it's a 1.
Here is where things get tricky.
We don't know if this is going
to be a B or C, because you
could see that both of their
code words start with a 1.
This means we actually have
to read another bit off
of the stream before
we can actually
make a decision about
which code this is.
So we read a 1 and a 0.
And we can see that it actually
corresponds to the letter B.
That means we read those off,
we output a B to the stream.
Now we do this again
for the next one.
We read one bit
again, because we
have to always start with
the least common denominator.
And we realize that
that could either be
B or C. We read in a secondary
bit and use that pair.
And we realize that we've
just read the letter C off
of the stream.
Now this is all
fine and dandy when
things are working correctly.
But the reality is
that it's really hard
to design and create the
proper variable length codes.
In fact, a lot can
go wrong in how
you're choosing what code words
are assigned to what symbols.
And this is where things can
actually get really wrong.
So let's say we end up here.
We end up with the same input
bit stream that we saw before.
But notice that the code
word for the symbol C
has actually changed.
It's now 1, 0, 1
instead of 1, 1.
So let's start decoding
and see what happens.
We read the 0 off
of the bit stream,
and we notice that
that's an A. Fantastic.
An A goes out to the stream,
and all unicorns are happy.
However when get to the
next one, we go-- read a 1,
and we realize that that could
be either B or C. Fantastic.
Still things that
we're doing normally.
However, when we
read the next 0,
we're still not clear if this
is a B or C. We can't actually
make a decision.
It looks like a 1,
0 should go to a B.
But this might actually
be a C. Because if we read
the third bit, we could
actually make that decision.
So what we're looking at
here is because of the way
we've encoded our VLCs, we
don't know if this 1 0 1 0 bit
pattern is actually
two Bs or a C
and an A. This
actually gives rise
to something you need
to follow when designing
your variable length codes.
And that is known as
the prefix property.
Or more specifically,
once a code
has been assigned
to a given symbol,
no other code can start
with that bit pattern.
So if we have 1 0
with B, we should not
be able to start the
letter C with 1 0.
That's going to make us
have a really bad time.
Of course, at this
point you have
to ask yourself where do
variable length codes come
from?
I mean they don't
just drop from the sky
into your computer for
your encoding purposes.
For this, we actually
have to introduce
someone named Peter Elias.
Now besides being a renowned
tap dance fusion instructor,
he also invented beta codes.
Or what we call today
modern binary codes.
Now as we talked about,
binary codes actually
aren't variable length
codes, because they
don't obey the prefix property.
But Dr. Elias didn't stop there.
You see, he actually constructed
an entire fleet of compression
codes that he used
for various patterns.
Now, in the early days
of creating these codes,
you could actually take an
integer value, such as 0
through 5, and actually
use that to denote
what type of generation on
the code you're going to have.
So for instance, this is
known as the unary code.
Probably the most simplistic
variable length code
that obeys the prefix
property that we have.
The way that unary codes are
constructed is given a specific
index, you actually append
that many 1's-- minus 1--
to the front of it before a 0.
So for example
down here at 5, you
can see we've appended
four 1's and a 0.
4 gives us three 1's and a 0.
3 gives us two 1's and so on.
Of course, because of the
way this is constructed,
0 actually doesn't have a
value representation here.
Now what's important
about the way
that Dr. Elias actually
constructed his codes,
was that they all were built
around a specific probability
distribution.
So unary codes are
actually optimal when
all of your symbols follow
probability set forth by P
to the n is 2 the negative n.
Now if your symbols
don't actually
follow this probability,
you're going
to get a little bit
of bloat in your codes
later on in the stream.
And you're actually not
going to hit entropy.
But unary codes aren't
the only thing he created.
Let's see here.
We've also got gamma
codes, which of course you
see have a completely
different construction process.
That's mainly because they
have a different probability
distribution down
here in the bottom.
As well as delta codes,
or a variant of that.
And themselves are actually
constructed quite differently,
and have this monster of a
probability in the bottom.
And of course we have
the fabled omega code,
which is known to many far and
wide for having one of the more
complex probability
distributions
that you can't actually list it.
It's kind of like saying
Voldemort out loud.
Anyhow.
Back in the day,
the way that you
would choose what variable
length code to actually encode
with is you would actually look
at the probability of your set
and sort of determine how
many symbols you would have,
against which code is
actually going to give you
the optimal encoding
for that set.
So for example, if you have
somewhere between 64 and 88
unique symbols that
needed code word,
you could actually find that
if the probability matched
properly, you could
use omega codes
and get the best bit
pattern you needed.
Of course, if you
were lower than that,
you may need to choose gammas.
Or somewhere in the middle,
you may need deltas.
Of course this brings us
to an interesting question.
If you have a set of
symbols that don't actually
follow any of these known
probability distribution
functions, what do you do?
Well of course the issue
with that-- let's see here--
is that there are hundreds
of variable length codes
out there.
You see, we've got Schalkwijk
codes, Phased-In codes,
Punctured codes, Stout
codes, Fibonacci codes,
and really there's a
lot to choose from.
Or you could do something
a little bit different
and actually construct
your VLCs based
upon your probability directly.
Let's take a look at that.
In 1951, while David Huffman
was still a student at MIT,
he was taking an electrical
engineering class
where his professor
gave him an opportunity.
He could either
write a term paper
solving a very
difficult problem,
or he could study for his final.
Of course David, being a little
bit optimized at the time,
decided that he would
rather solve a problem
than study for his exams.
Now the problem that the
professor gave him was
try to find the
most efficient way
to represent letters,
numbers and other symbols
using binary code.
Of course, David decided to
chomp into this full bore.
And after months and months
of chewing on this problem
was about to give up.
Effectively, he had
given up and was
to the point of
throwing away all
of his notes, when it hit him.
He would later say that
it was like lightning
striking his brain as soon as
the papers hit the trash can.
So what he developed
at that time
would later be recognized by
Donald Knuth as one of the most
fundamental methods of computer
science and data transmission
that we'd ever discovered.
See, what happened
was David Huffman
found a way to represent and
create variable length codes
for any given probability in
a very simplistic and compact
binary tree form.
Now later he went on,
of course, to figure out
how to levitate
things with his mind.
But until then, he
just used this code,
which we are going to
take a look at now.
Now the brilliance of
what Huffman discovered
was actually a connection
between assigning the symbol
to the code word
using the table.
Now what he was
able to do here was
find that if he
used a binary tree,
he could effectively use the
probabilities from the symbol
table alongside the
branches of the binary tree
to create an
optimal binary code.
Well let's build a Huffman tree.
So typically what
you're given is
a set of symbols with
their probabilities.
And the first step
in the process
is to actually sort them such
that the highest probability
symbol's at the
front of the array,
and the least probable symbol
is at the back of the array.
From here, what we're
actually going to do
is pop the two least probable
symbols off the array.
And actually make them
childs of a new node
that's pushed in there.
We actually continue
this process all the way
down the line.
Comparing the two last
elements of the array
together and making them
children of a new value,
that's then pushed
onto the array.
Now at this point we have a
fully created binary tree.
And to move from this tree to
the generation of Huffman codes
is pretty simplistic.
All we have to do is
assign a 0 and a 1
to the left and right
branches accordingly.
To actually generate the
VLC for a given symbol,
all we have to do is walk
from that node up to the root
and record all the 0's
and 1's that we trace.
So for example, A moving
from its note to the root
gives us 0.
B moving from the node to
the root gives us 0 and 1.
And moving from C to
the root gives us 1 1.
This effectively
is the generation
of our variable length codes
using the Huffman generation
algorithm.
And now that is a Huffman tree.
It's pretty easy to see that
a little bit of compression
can actually get you a long way.
And in something as simple
as statistical encoding,
you can use variable
length codes
to actually shrink
your data set.
Of course, the next thing
you really want to talk about
is what other
compression algorithms
are out there that you can
apply to your data stream
before applying these variable
length codes to actually get
you below entropy itself.
Of course, that's a
topic for different show.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]